the opening scene features a teenage boy
named Mark who wakes up just as his
mother leaves for work it appears to be
a fine sunny day and everyone in the
city is going about their work however
for Mark things are very different due
to an unknown cause he has been stuck in
an infinite time Loop for God knows how
long every night after 12 he wakes up to
the same day and the same things happen
around him in fact Marcus perfected his
daily routine through repeated
iterations of the same loop after
greeting his family members he
effortlessly Echoes their words at the
perfect time while out in the
neighborhood he is able to help other
people anticipating when the things
exactly will happen he helps people with
finding missing Keys hitching a ride on
the back of a truck and giving
directions to a woman without being
asked he even takes a bulldozer for a
ride while construction workers are on a
break one person he has become
particularly interested in is Phoebe a
girl who he helped with the directions
Mark seems to have developed a crush on
her and goes to the community pool to
meet her while there he saves her from
being hit by a beach ball and the two
begin to bond Mark walks Phoebe home and
before parting ways asks her to hang out
sometime however she bluntly refuses
seeking Comfort Mark visits his best
friend Henry who is playing a video game
where his character dies and responds
repeatedly this prompts Mark to wonder
what it would be like if he could have a
do-over in life and use his skills to
help others in need he imagines using
this power to prevent accidents help
people and generally make the world a
better place however Henry warns him
that with infinite possibilities come
infinite ways to fail and that if he
were to become stuck in the loop he
would never be able to move on from it
after waiting for midnight Mark
experiences the same day again due to
the time Loop he follows his usual
routine and goes to the community
swimming pool to meet Phoebe once more
however this time another girl named
Margaret unexpectedly saves Phoebe
before he this shocks Mark is someone
has changed his daily routine for the
first time since the loot began so he
tries to follow Margaret but only finds
a flyer for a missing dog that she
dropped before driving away Mark calls
the number on the flyer but it belongs
to someone else for the next few days he
continues looking for Margaret around
the city but she is nowhere to be found
it's almost as if she is a ghost however
one evening Mark spots someone leaving a
generous tip at a diner and assumes it
must be her to his amazement he does
find her and they strike up a
conversation as they talk Mark discovers
that Margaret is also experiencing the
same time Loop that he is with this
newfound connection the two spend time
together and Mark shares some amusing
coincidences he has observed during his
many Loops later when Margaret receives
a call and has to leave Mark asks for
her phone number since they are the only
ones aware of the anomaly in the
subsequent Loops Mark starts to find joy
in the routine and begins to experiment
with different hairstyles sending
pictures of himself to Margaret hoping
for a response unfortunately she doesn't
reply leaving him feeling dejected
nevertheless Mark persists and asks her
to meet up to which she agrees during
their meeting the two share their
respective experiences of living through
the time Loop Mark expresses his desire
to pursue Art School while also
mentioning his father's recent decision
to quit his job and write a book on the
Civil War Margaret on the other hand
talks about her ambition to work as a
mission specialist for NASA and shares
her struggles in finding a missing dog
she also takes Mark to a Serene Lake
where they witness a rare sight of a
kingfisher catching a fish Margaret
shares that she first saw it while
searching for the missing dog even
though it's pointless their conversation
is interrupted when Margaret receives a
call from someone named Jared she drops
mark off at his home before heading out
to meet Jared in the next iteration of
the time Loop Mark and Margaret spend
their day watching a group of skaters
perform one skater in particular a young
girl is ridiculed by the others until
she shows them a trick they have been
failing at impressing everyone Mark also
teaches her how to drive a road roller
the hell's that in the midst of all this
Mark asks Margaret about Jared to which
she responds that he's a med student and
nothing more as the day goes on Mark
Ponders if the time Loop is about
appreciating all the perfect random
moments that life has to offer Margaret
is skeptical but He suggests that they
should look for all the perfect random
things happening in their town on that
day Mark believes that by doing this
they can find meaning in their situation
hearing his last statement Margaret is
finally convinced the two then begins
searching for the moments of perfect
Beauty throughout the day and compiling
a list of them they discover rare
moments such as traffic being stopped by
a turtle crossing the road an elderly
couple playing chess
it's not perfect that's boredom
incarnate a pair of wings on a van
perfectly aligning with a man and a
construction worker playing the piano
beautifully one day Margaret decides to
teach Mark algebra claiming that she
cannot hang out with someone who doesn't
understand a logarithmic functions oh
God this plot is sinking fast after
spending the entire day together she
receives her regular call from Jared and
prepares to leave Mark asks her to skip
meeting Jared for one day but she
dismisses him and leaves the next day
Mark tries to search for information
about Jared on the internet but finds
nothing helpful he just learns about
some sicko from Subway feeling sad he
goes to his friend Henry and confides in
him about his recent feelings the latter
who is unaware about the whole time Loop
thing suggests that Mark take Margaret
somewhere special to show her that they
have a genuine connection taking his
friend's advice Mark takes Margaret to a
school gym where he has set up a mock-up
of Tranquility base the two of them
spend the day pretending to be
astronauts which makes Margaret very
happy at one point mark tries to confess
his feelings for her but he hesitates
and instead invites her to ride his bike
around the school later on they return
to Mark's house and wonder about how
they always wake up at the same time as
they look at the pictures he mentions
that his mother works at night which
means he barely gets to see her soon
after Margaret finds a map in which he
has mentioned all the perfect moments
they have experienced together Mark is
embarrassed about the map and admits
that he draws it every morning but
Margaret finds it amusing and encourages
him to pursue his passion for art as
they come closer Mark tries to kiss her
In the Heat of the Moment but Margaret
avoids it saying she only wants to be
friends this leaves Mark seriously
disappointed but he accepts her decision
they spend the rest of the day together
before Margaret leaves at 6 PM as usual
in the morning when Mark wakes up he
inquires about his mom for the first
time later that day his father Daniel
confronts him about his future plans but
Marcus frustrated so he simply rants
about his dull life he also calls his
dad hypocritical for not supporting his
dreams while he himself quit his job to
become a writer afterwards Mark talks to
his younger sister Emma who reveals that
their father was actually fired from his
job and was too embarrassed to admit it
moreover Daniel wants to send Mark to
art school but due to the weak Financial
condition of the family his hands are
tied hearing all this Mark becomes upset
as he shouted at his father earlier
without knowing the actual reason in the
afternoon he goes to meet with an
algebra professor at school to discuss
the cause of the time Lube Mark presents
his list of theories saying it's for his
assignment and the professor helps him
eliminate the ones that are unlikely
finally they come to the conclusion that
a singularity could be the cause of the
temporal anomaly and that if they could
Escape The Singularity they could also
escape the time loop as the time Loop
continues Mark grows increasingly
disillusioned with the idea of searching
for perfect moments in their small town
he tells Margaret that she shouldn't
trivialize things and stop trying to
distract him from the truth Margaret
misunderstands his frustration and
thinks he's upset because she didn't
kiss him in an effort to lift Mark's
Spirits she takes him to a show house
where they spend the day smashing things
eventually they lie down and Mark
Reveals His plan to escape the time Loop
by leaving the country he says that what
they have now isn't really living and
that they're stuck with everyone else
who never accomplishes anything feeling
dejected Margaret hesitantly agrees to
his plan the next day the two buy plane
tickets to Tokyo and board the plane
with High Hopes Mark is convinced that
if they can leave town they can break
free from the time Loop and save the
world he puts on an eye mask to relax
but when he removes it he realizes that
Margaret is no longer on the plane he
frantically tries to find her but it's
too late Margaret is backed out at the
last moment due to nervousness meanwhile
Mark spends the rest of the flight alone
drawing pictures of the small perfect
moments he and Margaret shared together
one of his drawings is of Margaret in a
space suit when the plane crosses the
International Dateline Mark holds his
breath in anticipation however the next
second he again wakes up in his bedroom
indicating that his plan has failed in
the next time Luke mark makes a
conscious decision to shift his Focus
away from his own desires and towards
other people he reaches out to his
father and expresses an interest in
learning about the Civil War showing a
newfound curiosity in his family's
history he also attends his younger
sister Emma's football game and
witnesses her scoring a goal that she
hadn't scored in previous Loops when he
wasn't there later Mark spends time with
an elderly couple playing chess and
appreciates the skills of the
construction worker playing the piano in
the afternoon he joins some skaters
attempting a move but it leads to a fall
and an injury as a result he has taken
to the hospital there as Marcus passing
his time nonchalantly he suddenly spots
Margaret curious about her reason for
visiting Mark silently follows her to a
patient's room and what he sees there
makes him speechless it turns out
Margaret visits her mother who is dying
of cancer and Jared is a medical student
looking after her this makes Mark
realize that he is not the main focus of
the story but rather it is Margaret who
holds the center stage he also realizes
that this has nothing thing to do with
Subway as the day progresses Margaret
feels the weight of her regrets and
missed opportunities in her relationship
with Mark she wakes up alone in her
house and thinks of her sick mother whom
she visits at the hospital Margaret
confides in her mother about how she
ruined her relationship with Mark but
the old woman reassures her that it's
never too late to make things right as
she leaves the hospital Margaret notices
the dog that she has been searching for
she thinks about returning it to its
owner but instead goes to see Henry
there Margaret introduces herself as
Mark's friend and helps him win a video
game by using a special weapon that's
how games work she discusses how the
concept of death whether in real life or
a game is distressing nevertheless
avoiding the experience of losing
someone would ultimately lead to losing
oneself deep at that moment Henry
initiates the game and reveals a map
triggering a sudden and profound
realization for Margaret following this
she returns home and creates a
three-dimensional model of the perfect
moments in town using string once
Margaret is done she notices that the
shadow cast by the model creates an
image of a four-dimensional cube with a
missing vertex she calculates that the
final event will happen at 7 pm at the
community pool String Theory you get it
the following day Margaret wakes up
early to visit her mother at the
hospital she feels overwhelmed and
tearful believing that if she finds the
last perfect moment the timely will end
but that also means losing her mother
hearing this Margaret's mother consoles
her reminding her to cherish life into
all the moments she's been given as the
clock ticks towards 7 PM Margaret
arrives at the community pool where she
finds Mark sitting alone she sits beside
him acknowledging that he was right all
along the perfect moments were connected
in a pattern she also mentions that
there was one missing moment which is
needed to end the loop Mark admits that
he saw her at the hospital and Promises
not to take her away from her mother in
response Margaret confesses that she
wished for time to stop when she found
out about her mother's illness and the
loop may have been a manifestation of
her desire but she now believes that
Mark was caught up in the loop too in
order to rescue her feeling relieved
Margaret finally leans in and kisses
Mark creating the missing perfect moment
that night Margaret visits her mother at
the hospital and bids her farewell for
the last time later she and Mark wait
outside nervous about what will happen
when Mark's watch strikes midnight it
starts to rain indicating that the time
Loop has ended the film ends when they
finally return the lost dog to its
rightful owner in the morning subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching